hello my name's well and I'm here with
great Haskins on the sticks out podcast
and Greg is a contact poisoner and
probably a close to five ball juggler at
this point and okay and lives in Boston
Massachusetts and as a Boston native say
hello Greg dad and I was kind of
interested having to have you on the
podcast you're probably one of the
youngest people I've had on the podcast
actually simply because they're kind of
like the bad guy of flow arts whether
you meant to generate that image or not
tell us a little bit about that let's
for sure what happened I don't know how
it happened I was just the when poor
chap went to shed and everyone moved
over to the florist lunchbox I started
communicating with a whole bunch of
people just like make jokes and be super
sarcastic apparently bags from the
outside looking in it probably is super
quick kids so yeah how do you feel like
I've met you in person and how do you
feel about people misinterpreting like
you're in person Greg versus your
Internet Greg just to kind of pull that
out there I wish more people would save
judgment until pretty like at least a
few hours you can really experience
online even people that I know that are
really nice whatsoever like Arashi for
example
No yeah he bothers me on the end up but
in real life he's a sweetie yeah I think
that's sort of like the byproduct of
sort of our scene
growing fairly largely to the Internet
the flow scene kind of a lot of
misinterpretations or misjudgments it's
kind of reason why I do this podcast too
right because I feel it's if people are
just people and it's not that big a deal
and I can think of people that I maybe
at some point I've had an interaction
with negatively on the internet or
fessor related but that really doesn't a
man into it just being a normal person
you know friends anyone else can speak
so like I'm like the in me like two
friends are cracking jokes that's what
you know let's talk about contact point
so contact boys your thing right and so
how did you get into POI in the first
place
let's start there how'd you get into POI
bunch of my friends I was super
resistant to that as well I was also of
course I went then they were great and
then a few my friends they saw the
crystal boy I'm sure you know the jokes
that we were make and yeah so one they
had been spinning for at least like six
look something like that
I was actually I was
havin fun with some psychedelics and
turns out I wasn't having fun and I just
wanted to do something to take focus and
like not I had my friend teach me
something boy and pretty much it's been
quiet since no I'm saying it so you
don't get us into you so Wow
so so like what kind of person were you
before you spun poi versus like after
you spun boy and I granted I know that's
not like a line like that night per se
but maybe in some ways it is yeah I was
such a different person I was looking
back it's like I didn't explain it
without going into like I could show you
YouTube videos of like things that were
like the cultures that I was involved in
but stereotypical like Boston hardcore
music moshing and get into fights
drinking and just being a [\h__\h]
[\h__\h] so that's that's like the whole
become scene that I was involved in for
like say ages 13 to maybe doing all the
drugs I don't even have the words to
explain the difference in who I am like
what I do do you feel as if spinning
props and that like practice regimen you
had
so to grind yourself into has improved
like other aspects of your life I'm
assuming you have some kind of practice
ethic and routine in your line yeah yeah
like practicing and accepting failure
itself pretty much any task that I do
like putting together IKEA it's
interesting it's a lot of patience
wait what'd you say patience yeah I used
to be like a very impatient person where
I came to like like figuring of anything
become more patient problem-solving
Cochran
[Music]
see that yeah I know so how did you find
contact boy then like how did like
contact boy I mean appear verse out of
like crystal boy one of the people one
of the guys who ran like a production
company that would throw as well some
won their first Super 3d videos just try
just
like pretty alright the first one I did
that was telling me the feeling of
throwing it and hitting your arm
rolling down sick I like the feeling of
like I would never know that this prop
would be able to do this thing unless
someone else told me that's a profit do
this thing was like I never I would
never pick up a snake in like blast an
angel like that would never happen I
would never like my mind would never
invent a way to figure that out but I
really enjoy that there's like a body of
technique that exists that has explored
the human body in contact with it like
from history because like assuming
you're probably finding a lot of I mean
contact juggling is fairly old art form
and baton twirling is old too so I
actually don't follow much because a lot
of it aesthetically it's different
enough so that's my eye the same way
there's something about the tethers and
they handle uncontrolled that looks ya
know I guess that's interesting just the
it's cool how it has the the dual nosov
like a rigid thing and a soft thing
right like which is kind of nice too I
mean now they have these like stiff
ropes I guess like the world is changing
for contact boy you use a stiff rope for
your contact for all you want nice
whimsy super flimsy not if whatsoever
really good plus two tangles yeah it's
great
everyone always liked waiting handles to
know wait in the handles
none not even I used to do I used to
have like five worked my way down to
zero watch it episodes I met Justin
Benson and he used to know did you ever
seen him that's right now yeah
JB thisone real dude where he was doing
so beyond me get his approval but not
really you know yeah no I think that
think that's a good point I think you
know it's funny cuz I mean I see badass
kendama on the internet and I went to IJ
this weekend that girl that woman Lisa
Khumbu Lisa
kendama or whatever like I saw her do it
in person and and she was like doing
like whatever Ken flips or the juggles
and stuff like that and I was like wow
someone actually can do that holy crap
I could probably do that sometimes it
just takes like an actual in-person
confirmation of ability like you can see
five ball on the internet but you know
once you have that five ball friend
you're automatically going to evolve
faster you know Justin changed my whole
perception of work what I thought was
good
yeah I don't know which is weird like
elevate the what I want to be able to do
so much and so you only do contact poi
and juggle are you like starting to like
broaden your spectrum of flow or juggle
stuff you know I've tried it's like even
when you feel like what are you thoughts
on the poi community before there's so
many different reach so yeah what are
your thoughts on like the poi community
in general like
what makes it so terrible but generally
speaking you're looking if you find like
five people so
it's changed a lot at least in my my
experience maybe that's just because I
travel needs a lot of the people that I
have impacted with online I don't know
it's so important it's such a [\h__\h]
boys club it's gross every other day I
see somebody getting yelled at for doing
saying something they shouldn't be
saying but it's also super easy to
forget though that in like specifically
for chat which is like the biggest
Facebook community most of the people
are like 18 18 19 20 to forget about
that so here I am 28
doctor 19 year old to think they're hot
[\h__\h] because they do a teaspoon flowers
and they're girls that like it I guess I
don't know but girl life it's it's great
everyone's a sweetheart
even if then you see somebody spin a toy
and then chance it's great everybody
vibes and learns from each other
ya know I think I could see that so I
wonder so what are your poor boy goals
in the next few years like what do you
want to do like what you're gonna make a
contact poi
I have the same idea yeah like what what
keeps you motivated to keep spinning and
doing stuff like this trying to
contribute
bringing this instructor realm that's
something that ya know I think you know
I'm finding this funny I was talking to
sage just now I'm just talking about how
can you keep spinning for 23 years you
know the thing over he's 50 you know I
was like damn and he's thinking about
like how do you stay she looks great but
how do you stay focused and on like stay
in it and I think said something it
seems a lot of deaths and rebirths and
over the course of her time as a fire
spinner and I know that might initially
sound sort of like yeah but it's
actually kind of true right obvious let
me down so many different life paths
guiding one maybe twice already
so like hmm where do you see poi going
like where would you like to see the
point community like move towards
because in a lot of ways you have that
power probably I have that power to sort
of steer it in a direction right like I
I personally I don't belong be Ricky
Bobby I'm just saying like I'm a part of
communities that that are still positive
like for example the Contacts tab
communities stayed pretty chill you know
I mean like some of the fan community
seems pretty chill the boo gang
community but for some reason this Pony
and you might be part of some of these
younger people but like how would you
like to see it grow or move in what
direction whether it's like you know
emotionally or technically or another
aspects uh me personally I would like to
see the community I don't even know
there's so many different factions of
the community like so many groups within
the three boys regardless of what I what
I want there's always gonna be some
everyone but I see a lot of people
trying to shift the focus over to
dancing that's great lies
I wanna play tricks just the spin
getting a [\h__\h] skirt
yeah man you be gliding all over that
place to sneak in there you know so yeah
yeah keep going I'm curious about this
question because no just like thinking
about the direction of POI because I
don't really spin POI as much as I used
to I literally spin it for gigs when I'm
mostly doing sticks or yeah you know but
I think it's heading juggling I think
everyone's just going to juggle yeah
which is fine everything leads back to
juggling some how are you gonna start
poor jungling or what
I'm not trying to do that every day if I
want to stay proficient
[Music]
well before we go I mean I feel like
ponies people like you to say stuff
sometime because I mean at this point
you're like a mentor of the boy
community I mean like I'm like
great-grandfather I'm like way down the
line you know what I mean there's been
like many since my time in that
community and I'm always curious like
how that can continue you know cuz a lot
of the POIs manners that are I mean
seems like Tim has been good being
positive supporter and some other people
are still positive support but like you
know I think the community needs people
like you you know to set them straight
you know yeah like going out of my way
to try it's tough especially when
everyone thinks you're an [\h__\h] you
haven't tried to set a positive example
yeah yeah I'm really into this I'm
recently been into the vtg land again
I'm almost finished I'm so happy dude
this will be it my legacy would be
you'll be done it's coming out on iphone
mike has to finish we just did like
around a thirty beta testers like 31
through but yeah that keeps me motivated
right like I mean I'm still gonna jog
I'm a juggler so I'm doing stick
shoulder pads at home and kendama hide
working on this app I've got a freakin
oakarina I'm learning how to play right
now so like so my trash you see that
video recently Chris released that video
of him doing the oh he also so alright
before we go I'm gonna ask you one two
questions you're a cat person right over
dog nice nice this is worth it this is a
good exit you know I would take this
silence oh my gosh Wow exactly too short
wow he's a toe what's his name yeah and
so he just has a huge body and little
legs huh yeah his shoulders okay alright
well Greg I appreciate your time being
here on a little little chat and I
appreciate thank you for no man I mean
there's be like the maximum 35 people
watching this then next year so we'll
see
five yeah but uh yeah well stay online
I'll talk to you later and everybody
else peace out thanks for watching
sticks out podcast we're going